okay i want to talk next about
the party
that claims to support our police
we must never defund we must never
restrict we must never limit the
techniques and tools and tactics that
police are able to use
and yet
they have been persistently and
consistently attacking the officers that
were there trying to defend the capital
on january 6th of this year the day of
the trump riots
we're going to look at a clip today
of newsmax host greg kelly
calling the police officers who
testified at those hearings about the
trump riots quote crisis actors
now we we even have to talk about that
term crisis actors crisis actors is a
term that in sort of general popular
culture to the extent that it's a term
people are even familiar with was kind
of popularized by extreme conspiracy
theorists like alex jones
i think my first introduction to the
term crisis actor was when alex jones
alleged that the parents of the victims
of the shooting at sandy hook in newtown
connecticut newton newtown i always
forget how it's spelled and pronounced
opposite uh under barack obama that they
were crisis actors they weren't really
the parents of the victims or there
weren't really victims and these were
high whatever
that's my first real
exposure to the term crisis actors and
in this segment greg kelly uses the term
to refer to the police officers now
remember greg kelly and republicans they
support the police and all of that stuff
okay let's take a listen uh as for trump
you know where he was on january 6 he
gave that speech i always said he had a
great alibi i mean number one he's not
at the capitol and number two he
specifically told people to uh
keep it peaceful right i know that
everyone here will soon be marching over
to the capitol building
to peacefully and
patriotically make your voices heard
now anybody who doesn't realize trump's
talking in code to his followers
you've got to understand the way dog
whistles work but that's not even the
focus of this segment all right so i'm
not a lawyer but here's what i would do
i would print off a picture of those
four
police officers at the
hearing a couple of months ago these
guys these some people call them crisis
actors i think that was a pretty apt
description
totally unprofessional
this is a law enforcement more than a
political question about january 6 in my
opinion a security matter uh but i would
not want to go in front of this phony
baloney committee and by phony baloney i
mean
this is phony baloney think about what
you have to believe
in order to follow these people in any
real way right the world is just full of
crisis actors and a false flags the
sandy hook shooting years ago they say
that was a false flag with crisis actors
the the impetus was to take people's
guns which by the way didn't happen
record gun sales weren't even able to
pass universal background checks after
sandy hook
the january six riots that was a false
flag by antifa or liberals to make
trumpists look bad
but it was also peaceful trumpists that
conflict they don't care it was just it
was a false flag
the police officers who were hurt
scared abused
they are crisis actors also to make
trumpists look bad but consider what
that even means crisis actor the police
officers were crisis actors does that
mean they're not really police officers
or they are but they're lying about what
happened or the videos
depicting what happened were staged like
what does it even mean to say that the
police officers are crisis actors it
doesn't matter
the government that supposedly in tr is
in charge
really isn't in charge as the basis for
a lot of this we talked about that
shadow government conspiracy yesterday
so it's a kind of package of conspiracy
theories sometimes it's called deep
state uh sometimes it's trilateral
commission illuminati the bilderbergs
the jews the vatican whoever they're
really in charge not the president and
the vice president and the normal
centers of power once you buy into that
general idea
it's very easy to be
convinced or tricked into believing that
the so-called police officers were
crisis actors they were hired it was
staged in some way shape or form and
what's kind of notable about this
is they don't even realize that they are
playing right into the propaganda of
foreign nations when they promote this
stuff including russia's disinformation
campaigns the centers of this
type of conspiracy in the u.s right now
are
uh right-wing evangelicals love and
spread this stuff
older white republicans love and spread
this stuff authoritarians just kind of
like fascist dictator wannabe
authoritarian types right-wing media
like fox news max oan although
there are some
of the republicans who don't subscribe
to this stuff
but this is exactly the type of stuff
that russia works to spread the us isn't
really in control the u.s is being
controlled by someone else you can't
trust american democracy democracy has
failed you can't trust the election
results this is the putin russia game
they don't even realize that they're
they're playing right into it out of one
side of their mouth they say
russiagate it was fake it was trumped up
it was rachel maddow and whoever but at
the same time they're spreading the
exact stuff
that the russian disinformation
propaganda campaigns want to spread and
if there's really a crisis actor isn't
it the people on newsmax pretending to
be news people like that's really the
acting that's going on
and sadly it's tricking a lot of people
a lot of people are falling for it and
they're not even questioning it in any
serious way so this is the latest now
the police officers who they claim to
support
are the crisis actors and then just like
as a final point which it must be made
any time we talk about right-wing
conspiracies about either the military
or the police law enforcement etc
they have the stated principle that they
support the troops and they support the
police etc
it's not really a principle they abide
by they abandon it as soon
as it's inconvenient to support the
police or support the troops in this
case if they support the police they're
supporting these officers saying it was
a trumpist violent madhouse doesn't work
so the principal gets abandoned
immediately they don't actually care
about the principles